[Aplausos]
[Música]
las imágenes son terribles y hablan por
sí solas ante el fracaso en el campo de
batalla una de las últimas estrategias
de Rusia en Ucrania está siendo
descaradamente atacar a la población
civil para dejarles sin luz ni calor a
las puertas del duro invierno ucraniano
un invierno en el Que las temperaturas
oscilan de media entre los dos y los
menos cinco grados Pues bien se estima
que para mediados de noviembre de 2022
en torno al 40% de toda la
infraestructura de generación energética
de Ucrania ha sido destruida y según el
propio gobierno ucraniano es posible que
la cosa no haga más que empeorar
helenski Rusia ha dañado el 40% de la
infraestructura energética de Ucrania
Ucrania avisa de más ataques a la
infraestructura mientras el alcalde urge
aquí a prepararse para lo peor durante
el otoño las tropas de Putin han estado
utilizando los pocos misiles y bombas de
precisión que les quedan junto con
drones suicidas comprados a Irán para
destruir plantas de agua centrales
eléctricas térmicas termoeléctricas e
hidroeléctricas y esto queridos amigos
resulta clave en un país en el que la
mayoría de la gente que vive en zonas
urbanas Depende para su calefacción del
calor que se genera de forma realizada
en estas plantas es decir que no solo
hablamos del suministro eléctrico sino
también de problemas con la calefacción
porque en Ucrania como ocurre en tantos
otros lugares la gente no tiene calderas
en casa sino que el calor y el agua
caliente se generan en grandes centrales
y luego se distribuyen por tuberías
hasta las propias casas pues bien el
resultado de los ataques rusos es que
tanto keef como muchas otras ciudades
están sufriendo restricciones
energéticas brutales menos horas de
calefacción el alumbrado público no se
enciende o lo hace al mínimo y muchos
negocios no pueden funcionar o lo hacen
intermitentemente Y es que por supuesto
aparte del frío y de las dificultades
que la gente está pasando para algo tan
sencillo como poder cocinar También
tenemos que tener en cuenta los daños a
la actividad económica
con la llegada del otoño y del Invierno
la Guerra de Ucrania se ha convertido en
toda una guerra de desgaste contra la
población civil ahora que el ejército
ruso parece convencido de que en el
campo de batalla no tienen demasiadas
opciones de Victoria lo que estamos
viendo por tanto es el uso del clima
como arma de guerra Tan sencillo como
eso Putin quiero utilizar el frío para
provocar olas de descontento y hartazgo
entre los ucranianos porque lo cierto Es
que una de las pocas opciones que le
quedan ya al kremlin para al menos
intentar escapar airosos de este
conflicto es que los propios ucranianos
digan Basta ya y fuerzan al gobierno de
zelenski a negociar esa parece
claramente La Apuesta del dictador ruso
pero un momento porque Más allá de los
planes de Moscú la realidad sin embargo
puede ser completamente diferente
[Música]
Y es que por sorprendente que pueda
parecernos Lo cierto es que el invierno
ucraniano puede terminar convirtiéndose
en toda una pesadilla para las tropas
rusas por mucho que los ucranianos se
vean obligados a pasar frío y a vivir en
mi oscuridad los rusos pueden terminar
llevándose la peor parte y la cuestión
es por qué no se supone acaso que el
invierno siempre favorece a los rusos
Cómo puede influir realmente la llegada
del frío la nieve y las condiciones
extremas en el campo de batalla A qué
bando puede beneficiar o perjudicar más
Pues bien todo esto y más os lo vamos a
contar en este vídeo pero antes esta vez
toca ver un poco de historia
el general invierno
[Música]
vale históricamente el invierno ha sido
uno de los grandes aliados de los rusos
por ejemplo en 1812 el gran ejército de
Napoleón fue vencido en Rusia por el
invierno sufriendo unas 380.000 pérdidas
tanto en los propios combates como por
culpa del hambre y la hipotermia algo
más de un siglo después en 1941 durante
la Segunda Guerra Mundial un dictador
por todos conocido condenó a sus tropas
a una debacle a un peor Hitler cometió
el mismo error que Napoleón lanzándose
los brazos del Invierno ruso sin que su
ejército estuviera habituado ni
preparado algo que le terminó costando
Al haber más tener que sufrir durísimas
derrotas por el camino se quedaron
decenas y decenas de miles de Vidas
Claro que esta no es toda la historia en
su historial Rusia también tiene malas
experiencias con la gélida temporal
invernal en 1939 por ejemplo durante la
Guerra de invierno entre la unión
soviética y Finlandia los soviéticos
tuvieron que desistir de invadir toda
Finlandia después de perder entre 130 y
160.000 hombres Aunque aquí al menos con
un tratado que les cedió algunos
pedacitos finlandeses sobre todo en las
regiones de karelia y sala
[Música]
Pues bien aunque habitualmente el
invierno ha sido un Aliado para Moscú la
situación de Rusia en Ucrania podría
terminar siendo muy pero que muy
parecida a lo ocurrido en Finlandia en
el 39 o incluso peor peor porque el
colapso del frente ruso de junto al
atasco en el dumbas no se ha producido
en invierno sino durante el verano y el
otoño y ahí por supuesto el clima pues
no fue un actor relevante el desastre
ruso ha sido provocado sobre todo por la
superioridad tecnológica y la
inteligencia suministrado Ucrania por
sus aliados occidentales además de por
su tremenda tenacidad Claro está una
ventaja que ahora el invierno podría
incluso acentuar Y es que amigos amigas
la temporada invernal puede poner las
cosas mucho pero que mucho peor para los
rusos Aunque por supuesto para los
ucranianos Pues tampoco será coser y
cantar porque una guerra en un invierno
semejante no es pan comido para nadie
pero ahora bien llegados hasta aquí la
pregunta es por qué le damos tanto
protagonismo al invierno como puede
afectar esta gélida estación al
transcurrir de la guerra Pues bien ya
sin más preámbulo veamos
un regalo envenenado
en esta ocasión Los rusos no son quienes
están sufriendo la invasión de potencias
extranjeras sino que ellos mismos son
Los Invasores lo que tiene muchas
implicaciones que pueden terminar
jugando en su contra y ojo porque en el
krem lo saben de ahí que con el ocaso
del verano Y la llegada del otoño hayan
intentado incrementar la presión
atacando objetivos civiles pero para
contaros exactamente porque el invierno
ucraniano puede terminar convirtiéndose
en toda una pesadilla para Putin el
kremlin las tropas rusas vamos a
destacar Cuatro motivos principales Y sí
el primero de ellos tiene mucho que ver
justo con el propio teatro de
operaciones o más bien con luchar fuera
de Rusia hablamos por supuesto de los
suministros a las tropas Y es que aunque
la guerra está concentrada en las zonas
fronterizas que son en teoría a las que
Rusia pueda abastecer mejor lo cierto Es
que en invierno esta misión puede no
resultar nada sencilla y es que veréis
buena parte del frente especialmente el
de la región de kerson está lejos de sus
centros de suministros y producción y sí
es que 8 años después de su anexión
crimea sigue siendo abastecida
fundamentalmente desde Rusia y a ver Es
verdad que otras zonas del conflicto
como el obras de dones sí que cuentan
con buenas conexiones con por ejemplo
rostov del Don una gran ciudad
Industrial rusa de más de un mi pero el
resto del frente sin embargo no tiene
tanta suerte
[Música]
obviamente tener que movilizar equipos
pesados y grandes envíos de todo tipo de
suministros por suelos y carreteras
congeladas no suele ser una tarea nada
sencilla Así que en invierno Rusia
dependerá aún mucho más del transporte
por ferrocarril El problema es que las
líneas férreas además de ser mucho más
rígidas no llegan a todas partes también
están más expuestas que las carreteras Y
si los ucranianos consiguen cortarlas
con ataques y sabotajes entonces los
rusos pueden ver multiplicarse los
problemas que ya tienen para abastecer a
su ejército y en invierno la falta de
suministros puede ser decisiva por
contra los ucranianos juegan en casa y
eso en términos logísticos es una
ventaja enorme
Pero eso no es todo para luchar en
invierno hacen falta sobre todo dos
cosas preparación y equipamiento
pocas cosas antojan más complicadas que
luchar a varios grados bajo cero y tener
que hacer frente a la nieve y el hoy y
la congelación Pues bien aquí los
ucranianos pueden llevarla delantera Y
es que sobre este punto pues en fin creo
que la mayoría ya conocéis la historia
las tropas movilizadas rusas están poco
entrenadas y carecen de equipos
adecuados para la guerra los soldados
movilizados rusos hablan hemos sido
tirados al frente sin apoyo la enorme
cantidad de bajas sufridas que por
ejemplo las fuentes occidentales
calculan en cerca de 100.000 hombres
entre muertos y heridos han hecho que
los rusos tengan que tirar de reclutas
forzosos
es decir nuevo soldados recientemente
movilizados a toda velocidad que en
muchos casos prácticamente no han
recibido ningún entrenamiento antes de
ser enviados al frente e incluso los que
han tenido más fortuna apenas han
recibido una preparación del todo
insuficiente Y sí podríamos pensar que
los ucranianos se enfrentará una
situación muy similar sin embargo hay
algunas diferencias importantes primero
no es lo mismo jugar en casa y combatir
en tus propias ciudades que hacerlo en
un país extranjero sin conocer El terre
sin tener el apoyo de la población y con
la moral por los suelos segundo hoy
Ucrania tiene el campo de batalla más
soldados con experiencia profesional que
Rusia aquí las fuerzas de defensa
territorial han sido todo un éxito y
tercero muchos soldados ucranianos
soldados profesionales o con cierta
experiencia de combate están recibiendo
entrenamiento de primer nivel por
ejemplo los británicos llevan meses
entrenando a tropas ucranianas y ahora
muchos otros países europeos han
empezado a hacerlo propio 17 de octubre
de 2022 los estados de la Unión Europea
acuerdan entrenar a soldados ucranianos
como parte de una nueva misión con lo
cual la priori parece que si hablamos de
know house de saber hacer los ucranianos
También tienen ventaja sobre los rusos Y
eso eso es algo que en invierno vale
doble pero sigamos
el tercer gran motivo tiene que ver
precisamente con el equipamiento que
tiene nos alcance los propios soldados y
es que prácticamente desde el comienzo
de la invasión rusa de Ucrania una de
las cosas que más han llamado la
atención Es que muchos soldados rusos no
cuentan con equipos individuales
avanzados y la cosa con el paso de los
meses no ha hecho más que empeorar el
ejército ruso no a los nuevos soldados
reclutados absolutamente ningún
equipamiento forzando a las familias a
comprar blindaje y ropa para que los
reclutados tengan una oportunidad de
regresar sabemos que 9 meses después de
comenzar la invasión los almacenes del
ejército ruso están tiritando hay
escasez de misiles de tanques modernos
de munición Y sí también de equipos
individuales
[Música]
combatir en condiciones de frío extremo
hielo y nieve requiere de equipos
específicos por ejemplo las botas de los
soldados tienen que ser especiales para
soportar bajas temperaturas y poder
caminar sobre el hielo y los ropajes han
de ser térmicos y a la vez ligeros para
permitir el movimiento dada las
condiciones climáticas de Rusia
podríamos pensar que su ejército está
bien abastecido de todas estas cosas
pero lo cierto es que todo apunta a que
no es así Las crónicas que nos están
llegando desde el frente apuntan a que
los nuevos soldados rusos llegan
prácticamente con las manos vacías y
desde luego los equipos modernos brillan
por su ausencia
[Música]
Mientras tanto los sucrenos pues llevan
ya Messi recibiendo toneladas de
equipamiento individual adaptado al
invierno procedente de sus aliados
occidentales con lo cual es muy probable
que el ejército de ya esté cubierto la
otan está enviando equipos a Ucrania
mientras las tropas se preparan para el
invierno los países occidentales están
acelerando los envíos de ropa de
invierno nuevas rondas de artillería y
defensas contra drones akif mientras las
fuerzas ucranianas y rusas se preparan
para una lucha de meses en medio del
barro y el hielo y sabéis que
Exactamente lo mismo ocurre con el
Hardware militar Pesado
[Música]
en Ucrania cuando empiezan las primeras
Nevadas estas acumulan y se convierten
prácticamente en duro hielo un hielo que
permanece hasta la llegada de la
primavera y ojo Porque después del hielo
lo que llega es el barro que puede
terminar siendo incluso peor todo esto
hace que ambos ejércitos sean mucho más
propensos a usar las carreteras que
suelen conservarse más limpias o al
menos es más fácil tenerlas limpias en
lugar de intentar avanzar campo a través
o por caminos Rurales básicamente porque
moverse por ahí puede resultar siendo
todo un infierno De hecho no sé si
recordaréis que en febrero y marzo
durante el primer mes de la invasión
cuando todavía había montones de nieve y
de hielo en Ucrania los rusos siempre
avanzaban por las carreteras municipales
y ese fue uno de los motivos por el que
sus largos convoyes Se volvieron muy
vulnerables recordáis cuando camiones y
blindados rusos se quedaban atrapados
Porque esos neumáticos explotaban al
estar caducado os acordáis de las
emboscadas ucranianas que terminaban con
numerosos equipos rusos calcinados Pues
eso y para colmo todo eso pasó en
febrero y marzo que es cuando los rusos
contaban con más medios a su alcance y
más diferenciadas respecto a las tropas
ucranianas Así que imaginaos lo que
puede ser ahora Durante este invierno
amigos amigas puede hablando de las
distancias un escenario muy parecido
fijaos
los rusos saben de sobra que sus
anticuados tanques blindados y camiones
no se desenvuelven bien campo a través
en invierno con lo que es probable que
se vean menos enfrentamientos en campo
abierto además en el invierno las
condiciones meteorológicas son mucho más
adversas como lluvias Nevadas tormentas
o Niebla que entorpecen las operaciones
de los drones tan necesarios para ambos
bandos para fijar objetivos y utilizar
armas de precisión por este motivo una
de las posibilidades que se barajan de
cara al invierno Es que la guerra aún
sin detenerse entre en una especie de
fase de letargo en la que las
operaciones que veamos sean de mucha
menor escala y desarrollos mucho más
lentos sin embargo al mismo tiempo las
duras condiciones climáticas y los
movimientos más difíciles por el terreno
hacen que los equipos sufran mucho más
y sabéis que nada de esto juega tampoco
a favor de los rusos una guerra más
prolongada exige un esfuerzo de
suministros continuo y luego con el
desgaste de los equipos los rusos pueden
tener muchos más problemas básicamente
por el hecho de que Ucrania cuenta con
armamento pesado más moderno o incluso
aunque no lo sea este suele estar en
mejores condiciones de mantenimiento
por ejemplo muchos de los tanques t-72
que usa Ucrania hoy en día han sido
donados por Polonia y han sido
entregados en perfectas condiciones de
uso después de ser reacondicionados y lo
mismo ocurre con otros tanques y otras
armas de países como República Checa por
ejemplo y no solo eso los aliados de
kife en la región como Polonia
Eslovaquia o la propia República Checa
reparan habitualmente equipos militares
ucranianos e incluso los actualizan
Hablamos de una cadena de mantenimiento
actualización y modernización de armas
que se ha creado sobre la marcha y que
está permitiendo a ucranianos estar unos
cuantos pasos por delante de Rusia
evidentemente no podemos saber que va a
ocurrir exactamente pero amigos amigas
todo apunta que esta vez el invierno no
favorece a los intereses del kremlin y
quizás precisamente por eso es por lo
que hemos visto y todavía seguimos como
la nueva apuesta de Rusia en esta guerra
pasa precisamente por llevar a los
ucranianos de una vez por todas a la
mesa de negociación en esta línea La
amenaza de usar armas nucleares
hablaremos Por cierto de ello muy pronto
aquí en visualpolitik y los ataques a
las infraestructuras civiles que veíamos
al comienzo del vídeo cobran mucho pero
que mucho sentido digamos que todo nos
hace sospechar que en el kremling son
perfectamente conscientes de que esta
vez el invierno no les favorece pero
ahora ha llegado hasta aquí turno para
ti crees que Rusia conseguirá soportar
un invierno en la guerra mejor de lo
esperado piensas que los ucranianos
deberían resistir el embate Ruso y el
chantaje energético o deberían abrirse a
negociar con Putin déjanos tus opiniones
por aquí abajo en los comentarios y
recuerda si este vídeo te resultó
interesante No olvides darle a like y
suscribirte a nuestro canal Para no
perderte ninguna novedad también puedes
ayudarnos a quedar más y mejor contenido
sumándote a nuestra comunidad de patreon
además recibirás un montón de beneficios
una vez más Muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]